er hatte solch einfach kurz bisschen
benzin treffer sollte und herzlich
willkommen zu einem ganz speziellen
video dem titel schon gesehen heute hat
es irgendwas mit explosion amerikaner zu
tun als allererstes ideale voraussetzung
heute denn wir haben max hinter der
kamera und werden in der kamera einen
akku der schwer beschädigte die kamera
jederzeit explodieren legen wir los oder
ihr habt ihr gesehen oder wir werden
heute alle knallen auf machen zusammen
mischen und dann einen riesenknall
sprengstoff mischung daraus machen und
die zünden jugendschutz gut vorbildlich
so zwei drei richtig gesagt trinkt
alkohol private anders rum trinkt
alkohol trinkt nehmen keine drogen und
macht einfach nicht die scheiße nach die
ich dummkopf euch in dem video formate
leute fangen wir an leute wie haben hier
zwei verpackungen über 140 einzelteile
marxheim 83 einzelteile und dann hab ich
mag es noch die cloud die er gekauft hat
jetzt werdet ihr sagen okay da steht
jugend feuerwerk drauf legt daher leute
die gehen nicht geglaubt dass ich tanzen
also älter als 13 mitarbeiter leuten ist
wie man sollte damit über diese folie
werde ich alles auf machten zusammen
mischen und dann eben diese alufolie
quasi zum kleinen topf bauen und
irgendwie mir dann überlegen wie ich das
zu ende vielleicht mit sondern benzin
spur wien so pino fall sah ich sehe das
kapital schon alter escape ein solares
nachgemacht komplett münchen es
verdorben explodiert
sorry leute wirklich heute macht es
nicht zu hause nacht könnte ich
gefährlich seien keine professionellen
okay leute das ist der blick
das ist wir haben knatter fritz
selbstverständlich wir haben pyro kreise
wir haben silber wirbel wir haben tolle
biene wir haben für wirbel
wir haben geister lichter und flitze
feuerstein selbstverständlich falls
einer von euch sich gefragt hat wo
fühlst du volker stein jetzt ist hier
ist ganz cool ich habe mich auch etwas
wurst pilze vorstellen ich habe das
gericht dabei alter und das habe ich
natürlich zweimal leute okay leute gebt
euch das hier das sind so silber
fontänen silber blüten also diese dinger
die zum anschießen die so auskennen das
doch wie dazu die leute ich hatte so
eine fontäne mal eine große als reibe
feuerwerk dann bist ja aufpassen dinge
die haben keine tisch nur sein ding oben
was man so an haut mit unserer feier
geht es ging an
ich hab natürlich gedacht interessant
gras macht man das fahrzeug dann muss
man darüber reiben fleisch und dann ist
mir das ding richtig cassens auge
geschossen wurde in einem hotelzimmer ja
ich hab's einem porträt zu weit wir
haben in einem hotel zu meinem silvester
urlaub gemacht würde seht ihr das da ist
so eine schattierung drin
diese eine schatten von der profile nach
rechts unten das ist einfach von diesem
feuerwerk glaubt er zumindest
aber leute egal ich bin trotzdem hier
für euch da haben wir machen es jetzt
auch dann alles zusammen leute ich hab
halt überhaupt keinen plan wie die ganze
sache ausgehen wird das mega zeit
explodierte obst überhaupt nicht zündet
wir werden versuchen das zu nett und
notfallmedizin drüber
stell dir mal ganz kurz die schlagzeile
vor wenn jetzt irgendwas nochmal angeht
so wie youtube siemens health club das
wäre also lasst uns vielleicht mal aus
dem haus überhaupt stehen müssen das
zeigt wie es ist und weshalb es nicht
machen sollte bleibt aber dabei geht
über die riskieren ihr leben verläuft
reviews bis freund der ansatz ist leute
wiederholt an seiner tankstelle
feuerzeugbenzin schütten das drüber
tränken feuerzeugbenzin und legen damit
dem vortrag benzin so eine spur weg so
dass man quasi sich in sicherheit
begeben kann und nationen kann aber
durch ihr kein falscher eindruck bekommt
wir machen das alles auf privatgelände
das ist abgesperrt also kann auch
niemand reinlaufen er ist auch nicht
öffentlich zugänglicher zeit damit
niemand gefährdet drei tage später sogar
jetzt sind wir hier auf dem abgesperrten
teil wirklich wichtig zu sagen dass es
keinen job es ist echt ein abgesperrter
platz zu machen dass nicht auf
öffentlichen plätzen einfach nur damit
ist damit ihr nicht entweder komplett
gestört
ich hätte mir signale in dieser tüte
hier ist das feuerzeugbenzin was du
genutzt werden und dinge an zu machen
das braucht man eine probe mit
feuerzeugbenzin oder okay leute mache
jetzt jemand es hier ist nicht aber die
ist da jetzt einfach in die klasse
also machen wir das nicht sagen
also ich wollte gut brennt bezieht das
ist schon mal schief gegangen deswegen
werde ich jetzt einfach ein bisschen
beziehe die tüte reinhauen unternehmen
rein verlassen und dann der kristallinen
um mein leben ich glaube immer noch dass
es nicht übertreibe war auch nicht alles
was recht ist gut freute sich ok und
jetzt nachdem ein kracher an weil ich in
berlin eltern oder der meinung wo landet
ok das hat
ok bestätigen
[Musik]
private da haben wir noch
was da kommt immer noch was kommen ja
okay was dein fazit das fazit ist benzin
brennt nicht
das echt komisch natürlich ist auch
damit so leute wie du vielleicht ist es
möglich dafür gemacht hast du ja
youtuber die eigentlich die geistige
reife haben sollten das nicht zu machen
dann halt eben nicht das zeug kaufen
damit sachen also leute die lektion des
heutigen tages benzin brennt nicht und
obwohl wenn sie nicht brennt kann man
mit einer plastiktüte voller jugend
feuerwerkskörper eine menge spaß haben
ein bisschen heran und drückt uns die
überbleibsel anderes scheint tatsächlich
alles für mich zu sein ja kurz einziehen
mein gott das war so unvernünftig wir
sind so wie gerade dran den halter wie
du hast einfach wieder hier rein gehen
können oder wartet das las lasst einfach
leichter wird es nicht traut dem braten
nicht bis dieses tracks vorausgegangen
ja wir müssen uns auf jeden fall noch
beaufsichtigen leute auch während des
feuerwerks auswahl an silvester geht
einfach nicht so nach mit euren
gesichtern
ich habe jetzt schon zwei beispiel dafür
einmal das gerade eben das was von
diesem video leute wenn euch die folge
gefallen hat und hier weiter findet dass
ich dumm sagt in meinen videos machen
sollte könnt ihr jemand kanal abonnieren
und hier eine folge von was es geht vom
ende juni abbrechen da habe ich eine
online schule besucht also quasi eine
schule wo schüler nicht mehr in die
schule gehen müssen sondern einfach so
über das internet unterricht haben es
war